es gibt keine wirklich guten fertigen
nudelsaußen ihr könnt mir das glauben
denn ich habe so ziemlich jede getestet
klar der Griff zum Supermarkt pesto ist
einfach es kostet wenig geht schnell und
erfüllt seinen Zweck will man zumindest
mein aber auch nur so lange bis man mal
wirklich frisches Pesto gegessen hat ich
meine ich geb's ja zu ich bin ziemlich
verwöhnt ich durfte durch meinen
YouTube-Kanal in einigen der besten
Restaurants der Welt Essen und
unglaublich gute Pasta schmecken doch
schon vor meiner Zeit auf Youtube durfte
ich durch meine eigene Mama lernen was
wirklich gute Pasta ist meine Mama hat
einen Großteil ihrer Kindheit in Italien
verbracht und spricht nicht nur fließend
italienisch sondern hat auch von klein
auf die italienische Küche verinnerlicht
als ich klein war gab es für mich nichts
besseres als von der Schule nach Hause
zu kommen und von meiner Mama einen
Teller Pasta mit frischem Pesto serviert
zu bekommen und jedes Mal wenn ich bei
anderen Kindern zu Hause Pesto aus dem
Glas gegessen habe hat's mir einfach
nicht geschmeckt ich sag ja ich bin
verwöhnt aber das ist einfach was
anderes was meine Mama da gemacht hat
und jedes Kind dass das Pesto von meiner
Mama probiert hatte wusste auch genau
warum 10 Jahre später konnte ich meine
Leidenschaft zum Beruf machen ich begann
mich mit dem Kochen auseinander Z setzen
und habe die Bedeutung von hochwertigen
Zutaten und guten Rezepten kennengelernt
irgendwann hatte ich noch mal wenig Zeit
stand im Supermarkt vor dem socenregal
und dachte mir komm gibst du dem ganzen
noch mal eine Chance ich habe ein Pesto
gekauft es probiert und auch 10 Jahre
später schmeckt das immer noch fertig
und abgestanden und da habe ich mich
gefragt muss das so sein
2021 in diesem Jahr habe ich zufällig
einen Produktentwickler kennengelernt
der für große Supermärkte Produkte
entwickelt ihm habe ich erzählt dass ich
es einfach nicht glauben kann dass es
keine guten fertigen Soßen und er hat
gesagt ja lass uns do mal was
ausprobieren gemeinsam haben wir ein
paar Soßen entwickelt die dann einige
Wochen später zu mir nach Hause
geschickt wurden und das Ergebnis ich
muss leider ganz ehrlich sagen da war
nichts dabei also das hat mich nicht
abgeholt und war irgendwie nicht besser
als das was es schon gibt aber woran lag
das wenn man eine frische Soße bei sich
zu Hause kocht egal ob eine Bolognese
ein Pesto oder eine Carbonara braucht
man immer frische Zutaten frisches Ei
panchetta Basilikum und frische Zutaten
werden nun mal schnell schlecht wenn man
diese Soße also in ein Glas füllt ist
sie nur wenige Tage haltbar also muss
man die Soße haltbar machen und um Soßen
haltbar zu machen gibt es eingängiges
Verfahren davon habt ihr bestimmt schon
mal gehört die pasturisierung bei der
pasturisierung wird ein Lebensmittel für
einen kurzen Zeitraum hoch erhitzt
wodurch die natürlich enthaltenen
Bakterien weitesgehend abgetötet werden
das kennt ihr vielleicht von Milch wenn
ihr haltbare Milch mit frischer Milch
vergleicht merkt ihr wie stark sich der
Geschmack verändert was natürlich super
wichtig ist aber ein Großteil des
Geschmacks geht verloren und das gleiche
passiert bei Soßen und daher kommt
dieser typisch
fertige Geschmack gucken wir uns mal
gemeinsam die Zutatenliste von einem
zufälligen supermarktpesto an wir haben
Basilikum Pflanzenöl also Sonnenblumenöl
Rapsöl Sojaöl oder Olivenöl
italienischer Käse Pecorino Romano Cason
Nüsse Dextrose extra virgine Olivenöl
Maltodextrin Kartoffelflocken
Molkepulver Pinienkerne Milchsäure
basilikumextrakt das ist eine Menge aber
warum werden all diese Inhaltsstoffe
verwendet die Antwort ist recht einfach
es geht ums Geld denn damit wird es
einfach günstiger es zu produzieren wenn
man ein echtes frisches Pesto machen
will braucht man folgende Zutat Parmesan
Basilikum Olivenöl Pinienkerne Knoblauch
und optional ein Spritzer Zitrone
insgesamt kostet dieser Einkauf also
ungefähr 8 € und auch wenn man die
Mengenrabatte berücksichtigt bleibt den
großen Unternehmen einfach zu wenig
Gewinn also sie wollen mehr gewinnen
also noch mal eine frische Soße kann
nicht haltbar gemacht werden ohne den
Geschmack zu zerstören als ich das
damals festgestellt habe war ich
wirklich ziemlich enttäuscht
andererseits konnte ich jetzt verstehen
warum es keine gute Soße im Supermarkt
gibt deshalb habe ich aufgehört Energie
in die Entwicklung zu investieren und
mich anderen Aufgaben gewidmet ganze
zwei Jahre vergingen in den ich immer
mehr übers Kochen gelernt habe ich habe
zum ersten Mal selbst Nudeln gemacht mit
nichts außer Mehl und Eiern meine erste
Carbonara zubereitet natürlich ohne
Sahne in einem gigantischen käseleib
habe ich eine cheesepasta gemacht die
wirklich lecker war und ich habe die
beste bologonese der Welt in Bologna
gegessen je mehr ich über Pasta gelernt
habe desto seltener habe ich fertige
Soßen und fertige Pasta gekauft weil der
Geschmack von frischer Pasta und
frischer Soße einfach unvergleichlich
ist wenn sich die Soße um die Nude legt
und man das perfekte Zusammenspiel von
Geschmäckern und Texturen spürt ist es
beinah wie eine Poesie klingt kitschig
aber ich liebe Essen eigentlich schade
dass so viele Leute niemals in diesen
Genuss kommen eines Tages bekomme ich
auf meinem Handy eine Benachrichtigung
eine E-Mail von einem italienischen
Absender sein Name ist Luigi und der
Betreff willst du die beste Pasta der
Welt machen ich kann mich noch ganz
genau an den Moment erinnern weil das
fühlte sich wirklich so ein bisschen an
wie Schicksal so als würde dieses alte
Projekt jetzt wieder aufleben und es
gibt neue Hoffnung ich bin ganz ehrlich
in dem Moment dachte ich das sei eine
ganz normale businessanfrage und habe
mir auch gedacht was kann Luigi denn
wissen was ich noch nicht weiß weil ich
hatte das Thema ja schon durch aber
trotzdem hat es mich irgendwie nicht
losgelassen keine 24 Stunden später
telefonieren wir zum ersten Mal Luigi
ist zwei Jahre jünger als ich und auch
er liebt es zu kochen er erzählt mir von
der legendären Pasta die seine Nonner
kocht und schwärmt von italienischen
Zutaten erklärt mir wie wichtig die
richtige Pasta für die richtige Soße ist
und dass die beste Soße der Welt mit
einer gewöhnlichen Pasta niemals ihr
volles Potenzial entfalten kann wir
stellten fest dass wir die gleiche
Mission haben also habe ich Luigi von
den Problemen erzählt auf die ich
gestoßen bin und was er dann gesagt hat
damit hätte ich niemals gerechnet Max
ich kenne das Problem aber ich habe eine
Lösung dafür wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin
konnte ich das in dem Moment nicht
glauben weil es war zu schön um wahr zu
sein deshalb wollte ich mich selbst
überzeugen und bin sofort nach Italien
gefahren Freunde es ist 6 Uhr morgens
irgendwo in Südtirol und für mich
beginnt vielleicht größte Reise meines
Lebens eine paserreise deshalb könnte
ich mich nicht mehr darauf freuen los
geht's Freunde was sind das für Szenen
no joke das stimmt mich alles so
geisteskrank hyed ich kann mir das gar
nicht vorstellen wir werden in den
nächsten Tagen hier in Italien einige
Produzenten bereisen für eine Sache die
eigentlich zu schön ist und wahr zu sein
ihr habt ihr schon gehört Pasta aber was
wir hier machen werden könnte wirklich
next level werden am Ende der ganzen
Aktion wenn alles klappt steht nichts
anderes als den pastamarkt in
Deutschland wirklich zu revolutionieren
und wirklich gute Pasta zu jedem nach
Hause zu bringen zunächst einmal wollten
wir die perfekte Nudel finden wer denkt
dass es keine großen Unterschiede bei
Nudeln gibt der IRT sich gewaltig
grundsätzlich unterscheidet man zwischen
frischen und getrockneten Nudeln bei uns
in Deutschland kann man eigentlich nur
trockene Nudeln kaufen aber in Italien
da kann man frische Pasta kaufen die
schmeckt wie s gemacht doch auch hier
gibt es Unterschiede günstige Pasta wird
in Keramik ausgeformt also der Teig
kommt in eineer Maschine und am Ende
wird er in Nudelform gebracht und bei
Keramik hält man eine glatte Oberfläche
das geht aber relativ schnell die
hochqualitative Alternative ist die
Ausformung in Bronze das dauert zwar
länger und ist deshalb kostenintensiver
aber die Pasta erhält eine rauhe
Oberfläche an der sich die Soße
festklammern kann also sind wir durch
ganz Italien gefahren um die besten
Nudeln zu finden wir haben gute Pasta
getestet wir haben schlechte Pasta
getestet est und wir haben sehr sehr
gute Pasta getestet Freunde erster
Termin wir werden noch einige
Produzenten treffen und ich muss jetzt
schon sagen sowas gibt es nicht also so
gute Pasta wie hier gibt's bei uns
einfach nicht zu kaufen das ist jetzt
schon geil wirklich Endstufe ganz ohne
Soße hatte diese Nudel einen
unvergleichlichen Geschmack beinah wie
bei einem Steak konnte man wirklich
einen garverlauf wahrnehmen außen weich
und innen der perfekte bis ich war
wirklich ein bisschen überrascht was für
ein Unterschied die richtige Nudel macht
nicht umsonst verwendet die tratoria
gigina wo die beste Bolognese der Welt
gibt ausschließlich frische Nudeln wenn
man die richtige Nudel und die richtige
Soße hat ist das wirklich wie ein
Gedicht wie eine Poesie die Suche nach
der perfekten Nudel war also erfolgreich
aber was bringt die perfekte Nudel ohne
die richtige Soße wir erinnern uns man
kann eine Soße nicht haltbar machen ohne
den Geschmack zu verändern das dachte
ich zumindest aber dann stellte Luigi
mir Carlo vor Carlo ist sowas wie der
pastapate von Italien mit seiner Firma
stellt der pastaprodukte für die ganze
Welt her doch Carlo ist stolzer
Italiener und er hast es dass die
Supermarktprodukte der italienischen
Küche nicht gerecht werden deshalb hat
er lange geforscht und einen Weg
gefunden mit dem man frisch gekochte
Soßen haltbar machen kann ein Verfahren
bei dem man ein Pesto wie meine Mama es
zubereitet haltbar machen kann ohne den
Geschmack zu verändern genau das was ich
immer gesucht habe aber all das klang so
schön um wahr zu sein deshalb haben wir
uns selbst überzeugt nächste Fabrik
nächster Ort erstmal
abswagen zunächst haben wir verschiedene
Soßen getestet erst pur und dann mit
Pasta doch dann sah ich es ein frisches
grünes Pesto könnte das das Ende unserer
Reise sein wir haben probiert und wurden
enttäuscht obwohl das Pesto wesentlich
besser geschmeckt hat als alle Pesti die
man im Supermarkt kaufen kann hat es
diesen typischen fertig Pesto
Nachgeschmack war also doch alles
umsonst Carlo hat gesagt dass dieser
Nachgeschmack auch an minderwertigen
Zutaten liegen könnte und hat uns
ermutigt einfach mal ein paar Soßen zu
entwickeln und mit dem Verfahren zu
testen also haben wir gekocht wir haben
viel gekocht und immer wenn wir nicht
weiter wussten haben wir eine besondere
Frau gefragt die auch ihr schon
kennenlernen durftet Luigis Großmutter
seine Nonna es mag klischehaft klingen
aber niemand kocht so gut Pasta wie eine
italienische Nonna die extra Portion
Liebe und jahrzehntelange Erfahrung
machen die pastakreation einfach
unglaublich gut irgendwann sind wir mit
einem Stapel voller exzellenter
Geheimrezepte zu einem Produzenten
gegangen und haben ihn gebeten teste
anzufertigen einige Wochen später war es
soweit und sie waren fertig also bin ich
mal wieder nach Itali fahren und ihr
könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie
aufgeregt ich
war gut Freunde 10 Uhr morgens irgendwo
in der Nähe von Udine gleich dürfen wir
die Rezepturen testen wir sind bei
unseren Produzenten und jetzt kommt
drauf an also jetzt wird sich zeigen
schaffen wir das was wir schaffen wollen
und zwar restaurantpasta für zu Hause
ich ich bin wirklich sehr aufgeregt also
ich bin sehr sehr aufgeregt weil heute
entscheidet sich ob wir da sind oder ob
wir noch eine ganze Menge Arbeit vor uns
haben aber leider war nicht alles so
rosig die Bolognese hat einfach nicht
krä heftig genug geschmeckt die
sahnesaußen Waren zu milchig und manche
Soßen haben sich getrennt aber warum war
das so der Koch hat einfach nicht mit
den besten Zutaten gearbeitet obwohl wir
das wollten weil er so fest steckt in
der Industrie er hat behauptet dass es
keinen Unterschied macht ob man einer
bologese Wasser oder Gemüsebrühe
hinzufügt er hat gesagt dass es keinen
Unterschied macht ob man haltbare oder
frische Sahne nimmt und er hat uns
gesagt dass unsere Rezepte mit unserem
Verfahren nicht funktionieren werden in
diesem Moment habe ich wirklich
verstanden warum es keine guten fertigen
Soßen gibt niemand traut sich niemand
ist bereit neue innovative Wege zu gehen
warum auch die Soßen verkaufen sich ja
aber so schnell haben wir uns nicht
geschlagen gegeben also haben Carlo
Luigi und ich Tage in der Testküche
verbracht und immer weiter
experimentiert wir haben jeden überzeugt
dass wir es einfach probieren wollen und
wurden schlussendlich belohnt wir waren
angekommen ohne wir Leute ich habe noch
nie noch nie so eine gute Soße gegessen
das
ist das ist unglaublich die sagen auch
ich habe mich verliebt ich habe mich
wirklich verliebt in diese Soße und das
kriegt man nach Hause unglaublich wir
hatten die perfekte Pasta geschaffen
besser als bei jedem Lieferservice und
besser als in den meisten Restaurants in
5 Minuten bei dir zu Hause zubereitet
ohne kochen zu können und wir nennen
unser Baby Pasta poesia ein omage an die
perfekte Verbindung von Pasta und Soße
wie eine Poesie jetzt haben wir also die
Möglichkeit jedes Pastagericht in seiner
bestmöglichen Qualität herzustellen und
wir haben eine Box zusammengestellt aus
drei Pastagerichten die es wirklich in
sich haben ich meine guckt euch dieses
Baby einfach mal an es ist wunderschön
und wir gucken mal gemeinsam rein es
macht mich wirklich stolz hier zu stehen
vor dieser Box öffnen wir sie ich habe
noch nie eine ausgepackt ihr seid gerade
live dabei wenn ich zum erst mal eine
auspacke ich mE allein das Klebeband ne
Pasta poesier hier vorne habt ihr
vielleicht gesehen Luigi Nonna hat es
auch geschafft ist auch dabei mama mia
das hier in der Mitte ist unser Pasta
poesia Logo ich bin stolz Leute ich bin
verdammt Stolz ich kriegt erstmal
Rezeptkarten aber ich verrate euch noch
nicht was drauf steht die Boxen kommen
selbstverständlich gekühlt bei euch zu
Hause an und eine ganz wichtige Sache
noch vorab wenn ihr dieses Video seht
ist
pastapoesia.deel live und ihr könnt auf
die Website gehen und diese Box
bestellen schaut unbedingt auch auf
Instagram vorbei um nichts mehr zu
verpassen und wir schauen jetzt mal
weiter was sich hier noch so drin
befindet wir haben ein Pesto Genovese
und guckt euch bitte einfach an wie
wunderschön grünes strahlt dazu gibt es
metzanike so wie sich es gehört so wie
es in Italien gemacht wird es ist immer
eine perfekte Portion von der du
definitiv satt werden wirst guck mir was
wir noch haben ich weiß es schon aber
irgendwie ist es trotzdem spannend
auszupacken wir haben Ragu aller
Bolognese mit Spaghetti alakitara das
ist eins zu ein die Soße und die Pasta
die ich gemeinsam mit der Nonna gekocht
habe und sie schmeckt auch so und das
ist wirklich crazy das zu sagen weil das
war ganz besonders als ich das mit ihr
gegessen habe und zum Abschluss eine
Creme Alter Tufo mit talatelle und ich
sage euch so viel das ist wirklich
besonders weil hier sind echte
trüffelstücke und natür natürliches
Aroma drin was man sonst so bekommt ist
eine ganz andere Sache ich bin wirklich
wirklich stolz wenn ich diese Produkte
gerade sehe und in meiner Hand halte
weil es sieht wirklich wunderschön aus
also da können wir uns selbst auf die
Schulter klopfen es ist echt hübsch
geworden und sie schmecken vor allem so
gut deshalb reden wir nicht lang rum
bereiten wir uns einfach mal das Pesto
zu weil ihr wisst nicht was für ein
weiter Weg das war und auch das Pesto
haben wir perfekt hinbekommen wir haben
nämlich diesen Nachgeschmack
rausbekommen es liegt daran dass durch
die Bank einfach schlechter vasilikum
verwendet wird wir haben wirklich jede
Komponente getest und Basilikum war es
wir haben richtig guten drin das
schmeckt verdammt gut und dabei erzähle
ich euch noch ein bisschen mehr ich habe
erstmal ein Topf mit 2 lit Wasser
aufgestellt und Salze das Wasser jetzt
gut aber keine Sorge falls ihr nicht
wisst wie man Nudeln kocht wir haben
natürlich auch eine perfekte
Zubereitungsanleitung beigelegt in der
ihr genau sehen könnt wie ihr das
jeweilige Gericht zubereiten könnt da
sind ein paar echt schöne Fotos drin und
wir bereiten uns die metzemanike mit
Pesto Genovese zu wir haben auch noch
kleine Videos gemacht wo jeder wirklich
zugucken kann wie es perfekt
funktioniert weil mit diesen Produkten
wollen wir wirklich für jeden möglichen
eine geile Pasta zu essen egal ob du
kochen kannst oder nicht Wasser kocht
metzemanike Kochzeit 5 Minuten und das
sind auch die 5 Minuten die die
Zubereitung braucht Tüte aufschneiden
und die gebe ich jetzt einfach ins
Wasser hinein die brauchen 3 bis 5
Minuten je nachdem wie viel Biss man
noch in der Nudel haben möchte ich nehme
eigentlich immer die perfekte Mitte
Timer auf 4 Minuten ja und so einfach
ist es jetzt können wir einfach nur
warten wir können uns schon mal unser
Pesto anschauen ich füh mich an als W
ich Werb videoide machen aber ich ma
auch ein werbevide N ist halt mein
eigenes Produkt und ich find es richtig
geil wir machen jetzt einmal das Pesto
auf diese grüne Farbe strahlt einfach
vor sich hin und das Besondere ist dass
von der Pasta über die Soßen alles made
in Italy ist es ist wirklich ein Traum
wie ihr seht haben wir uns vor allem auf
traditionelle pastaklassiker beschränkt
wir werden natürlich mit der Zeit auch
vegane vegetarische glutenfreie
Alternativen anbieten aber erstmal
gucken ob euch die Produkte überhaupt
gefallen bei allen Soßen nimmt man sich
immer ein wenig Nudelwasser raus sod
dass man später die perfekte Konsistenz
erzielen kann das kennt ihr aus meinen
Videos Nudelwasser ist immer die
Geheimzutat also schüten wir die ab dann
geben wir sie in eine
Schüssel ihr könnt das natürlich auch
einfach im Teller machen wir geben unser
pestoenovese hinzu die socen sind in
Plastik eingepackt aber die Verpackung
sind 100% recyc einfach mit dem Löffel
ein paar mal durchgehen dieses
wunderschöne grün erinnert mich an meine
Mama ohne Witz das ist einfach genau wie
früher es duftet einfach nur wunderbar
nach Basilikum nach Käse nach Olivenöl
und jetzt gebe ich noch ein kleines
Schlückchen Nudelwasser dazu dann wird
es so ein wenig cremig das Pesto aber
beim Pesto mag ich es auch wenn man so
die Stückchen noch ein bisschen schmeckt
also geben wir unsere Pasta auf einen
Teller m boah wirklich dieses Grün ne
eine Sache suche ich noch natürlich
gibt's auch Parmesan zu jeder Pasta wir
haben uns gedacht vielleicht habt ihr
keinen Parmesan zu Hause und so eine
Pasta so wie jede andere Pasta muss man
mit Parmesan genießen können deshalb
streuen wir den einmal drüber und es ist
einfach nur schön die perfekte Pasta mit
der perfekten Soße wie eine Poesie eine
Pasta poesia und jetzt probieren wir das
gut Stück in diesem Bissen steckt
wirklich viel Arbeit und ich bin so
stolz ich bin wirklich einfach stolz und
ich freue mich wenn ich es probieren
könnte lass wir un
[Musik]
schmecken ich hätte alles selbst machen
können ich hätte die Pasta machen können
hät das Pesto machen können und es hätte
genau so geschmeckt das ist wirklich
unglaublich vielen vielen vielen Dank
dass ihr mir ermöglicht sowas zu machen
es ist unbeschreiblich und fühlt sich an
als sei das mehr als ich so in meinem
Leben hätte machen könen es fühlt sich
wie etwas Größeres als ich selbst an das
ist crazy ich bin unfassbar stolz und
deshalb ist mir auch ganz wichtig dass
ihr wisst dass das nicht das xbiebige
nächste influencer Produkt ist wo jemand
seinen Namen oder sein Gesicht für
hergibt sondern das ist meine Aufgabe
gewesen ich stehe hinter Pasta poesier
und ich max bin sogar der
Geschäftsführer von Pasta poesia also
wenn ihr das probiert lasst es mich
wissen ich will dass es jedem von euch
da draußen schmeckt wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder das war ein
wildilderit und danke danke danke folg
pastapoesie auf allen Plattformen um
nichts zu verpassen ich bin ein bisschen
bisschen gerührt gerade davon lass mir
aber trotzdem mein Teller Pasta
schmecken und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder danke fürs
zuschauen bis zum nächsten Mal ciao ciao
eine letzte Sache noch es kann sein dass
die Produkte heute sehr schnell
ausverkauft sind deshalb haben wir uns
was überlegt und zwar kann man heute
beim ersten Drop schon für den zweiten
Drop vorbestellen wenn man leer
ausgegangen ist also selbst wenn ihr
heute nicht an eine Box kommt wir haben
nicht unfassbar viele produziert weil
wir wollten halt nicht gefahrlufen was
wegschmeißen zu müssen dann könnt ihr
heute schon vorbestellen fürs nächste
Mal da wird es dann noch ein paar Boxen
extra geben aber wenn ihr sicher sein
wollt bestellt auf jeden Fall heute und
eine Sache muss ich noch sagen aktuell
können wir nur nach Deutschland liefern
ich habe schon viele Nachfragen bekommen
wegen Österreich Schweiz das kommt
hoffentlich in der Zukunft aber jetzt
gerade geht es leider nur nach
Deutschland glaube das war alles was ich
sagen wollte ach ja tragt euch in den
Newsletter ein und werdet Teil der
Familie denn auch bei diesem Drop konnte
die Familie schon früher Zugang erhalten
vielen Dank noch mal für alles das war's
jetzt aber auch wirklich